necessarily so in this morning Saturday
session we are so excited about this
Bill Murray in his comedy classic
Groundhog Day nothing much changes for
the character played by the actor and
comedian in contrast Murray's career has
been full of surprises and the latest
has him singing in a band comprised of
classically trained musicians not in a
movie but in real life he's been making
us laugh for more than 40 years cool
drink
varmints from the early days of Saturday
Night Live to his decades as a
box-office star
but now Bill Murray has found another
way to entertain audiences by see the
actor teamed up with famed cellist Yan
Vogler to record the album new worlds
[Music]
Murray sings and reads American classics
he unbuckled his sword then he handed it
to the astonished flea accompanied by
Vogler along with pianist
Vanessa Perez and violinist Meera Wang
may you in the musical partnership began
when Murray and Vogler met on a flight
from Berlin to New York in 2013 three
years later
New Worlds was born let's go out with
something really hot to these folks the
big hits out of 77 Murray's fans have
seen him sing before
whether it was his character Nick the
lounge singer from SNL
[Music]
the karaoke see from his oscar-nominated
role in lost in translation or his
performance as Baloo the bear in the
live-action remake of Disney's The
Jungle Book and just this week he
performed another American classic
during his beloved Chicago Cubs playoff
game
[Music]
[Applause]
as Marie told CBS Sunday morning with
new worlds and his new musical partners
it's a whole different ballgame
by myself in the shower I'm just as good
as anyone else in the shower but when
well better than something maybe but on
the stage with these three
I'm elevated